you've criticized the government this
morning for
what you call complacency complacency
now you you personally abstained on the
deployment uh of troops to afghanistan a
decade ago just let be clear before we
get into the details before this summer
did you think it was right that british
troops should have been in afghanistan
well
i was skeptical about the reasons for
going into afghanistan 20 years ago but
i very much understood like many people
that there was a real and present threat
from al qaeda that had seen more british
citizens that lose their lives than any
other apart from the united states in
the 9 11 attacks and there was an urgent
and pressing priority to make sure that
the capability of al-qaeda was degraded
and that also therefore meant taking on
the taliban government that was in
charge i think what became apparent very
quickly though was that there was a
problem
with what that led to the secondary
objective which became as joe biden has
said in recent weeks about nation
building and trying to build a
democratic inclusive government in
afghanistan alongside the afghan people
proved to be something that was far more
complicated than those who took us into
afghanistan in the first place envisaged
i think there have been a series of
mistakes over the last 20 years by
political parties of all persuasions on
both sides of the atlantic i think at
some stage there has to be a lessons
learned moment but what was avoidable
and what should have been avoidable was
the chaos that we've seen in recent
weeks that's left us reliant on the
taliban for permission to evacuate our
own citizens and the afghans who helped
us and put many british troops in danger
we had 18 months to plan we shouldn't
have ended up here i'll come to that and
i'll come to that in a second but if i
understand what you said clearly i just
want to be sure that i'm interpreting it
properly
you came around to the view that we
should have been there
but you thought what we did or how we
executed the mission
was poor
no actually i i think that the work that
the british troops did in afghanistan
working alongside the afghan people is
seriously underrated when i talk to
friends in afghanistan the younger
generation who grew up especially girls
being able to access education millions
of them who would never have had those
opportunities there is a whole
generation of young afghans who have
completely different expectations about
their lives than the generation that
went before because of the work that our
british troops did over two decades not
just in terms of education but landmine
clearance which meant that the economic
opportunities for many afghans were
completely transformed there are there
is a lot to be proud of of the work that
our british troops did over 20 years but
one of the things that many are now
asking is was it all in vain because of
the chaos of the last 18 months and they
are questions that we're going to be
putting to the prime minister in the
house of commons tomorrow and that he
simply has to be able to answer
okay well i mean the question for you is
that do you think then that the
president of the united states mr biden
should have stuck to his august the 31st
deadline
or do you think that good work of which
you've just spoken should have been
continued irrespective
i think the problem was the hard
deadline whether it was august 31st or a
different date the problem was setting a
hard deadline for withdrawal and that's
the point that my colleague emily
thornberry who was then the shadow
foreign secretary made at the time that
the doha agreement was struck
with president trump was that a phased
withdrawal
would have meant that the afghan troops
the afghan security forces we could have
continued to work with them in order to
support them to continue that battle
against the taliban but instead a hard
deadline signaled to the taliban that
this was simply a waiting game they knew
that they had until the 31st of august
and then all troops so to be clear and
that appears to have had a major impact
on the morale of the afghan forces as
well so we've been very clear
president biden for that decision
to be clear a labor government
would still have british troops in
afghanistan today
no
no we've never we've never argued that
once the united states took a decision
to withdraw from afghanistan we have
accepted the government position that it
would have been unsustainable to allow
british troops to continue the foreign
secretary was asked this week at the
foreign affairs select committee where
their efforts made with nato partners to
see if an alternative coalition could
have been put together to allow
british troops and others to remain in
afghanistan and he
gave an answer which is very consistent
with what many of those nato countries
have told me and the labour leader
privately
which is that it would have been
completely unsustainable to do that so
the question became how do you have a
chaotic and orderly withdrawal of troops
and how do you continue to support the
afghan people and protect those gains
that we fought for for 20 years after
we've left that's what the government
ought to have been planning for they had
18 months and they simply didn't do it
okay
all right now talking about supporting
the afghan people we are where we are
should our government be talking to the
taliban
or should it be supporting uh
ahmed masood and the national resistance
army in the panchayat valley can't do
both
i think we have to talk to the taliban
and we've been urging the government for
some time to have a dialogue with the
taliban we have thousands of people
still in afghanistan the afghans who
assisted us but british nationals as
well some of those cases are very very
complex the defense secretary has been
suggesting to mps that they should if
they can they should just try to get to
the border any border and see if they
can get across but without safe passage
many of those people will simply not
reach safety we've got british nationals
in wheelchairs we've got children who've
been separated from their parents we've
got somebody who's on dialysis the truth
is that unless if we want to uphold the
promise and commitment that we made to
our own citizens and to many afghans who
assisted us over recent decades we've
got to have a dialogue with the taliban
we've got to ensure as a priority that
safe passage across the country we've
got to be talking to the taliban as well
about the functioning airport and
whether a country like turkey or qatar
could somehow guarantee the safe passage
of our citizens out of that airport this
is really pressing and urgent and there
is no choice at this current stage but
to have a dialogue with the taliban
that's different from diplomatic
recognition um which which is it would
be far too premature to to acknowledge
but dialogue is absolutely essential and
the government is right to have started
that belatedly
so this is
uh a clear statement that you would um
engage with taliban of course uh nobody
in the pancho valley is going to like
that very much are they that will be
seen potentially as a betrayal of those
who have stood out against the taliban
that within days uh
you're talking to people that you
have in recent days actually criticized
for their human rights record
but there's a big difference trevor
between dialogue and diplomatic
recognition this is a regime that came
to power through violence displaced the
democratically elected government that
has been going door-to-door hunting the
uk and people who supported the uk and
the u.s has been rounding up women in
the last 24 hours
and has an appalling human rights record
we've got to be clear-eyed about that
engagement with the taliban and i'm not
for one moment suggesting that we grant
them the legitimacy of diplomatic
recognition as the government of
afghanistan but we have to accept that
because of the chaotic way in which the
government has failed to plan over the
last 18 months we are now in a position
where if we want to evacuate our own
citizens and afghan nationals we've got
to talk to the taliban if we want to
uphold any of the gains of the last 20
years we've got to talk to the taliban
in fact there has been a recognition
even from the outset of the war in
afghanistan that a new government would
mean having some kind of dialogue with
the taliban the united states has been
doing it the united nations has been
doing it and we shouldn't change that
approach now okay um
if i may ask you uh about some domestic
policies this morning the general
secretary of the trade union congress
has called for
essentially a wealth tax
to pay for
uh nhs recovery uh and partic and also
for social care is labor is the labor
leadership going to back that plan
well the first i saw about them was on
the front page of the guardian last
night and i think the broad principle
that francis o'grady is laying out that
those with the broader shoulders should
take some of the burden is absolutely
right fixing the social care crisis is
going to cost a great deal of money and
the prime minister's plan
as we understand it he hasn't shared any
of the details with it but as we
understand it his plan is that he's
going to break his 2019 promise to not
raise national insurance contributions
and load the entirety of the cost of
social care onto the supermarket drivers
supermarket workers the delivery drivers
who are already struggling with high
child care costs high housing costs and
who kept us going through the pandemic i
think that's a really difficult ask of a
group of people who haven't done well
under this conservative government under
the la over the last 11 years and so i
think it's right to say that we need to
think much more creatively about this
and make sure that we don't
load an unsustainable burden onto people
who can't bear it
so so this
so this is labor uh squeezing the rich
until the pips squeak again which in
this context the rich includes people
who live in london and the southeast for
example who have quite a lot of help
wealth but it's wrapped up in houses
which are very expensive
this isn't just going to be billionaires
who pay this
this wealth tax is it
i just i don't really accept any of the
premise of that statement i think that
most people in this country every family
including my own is touched by the
social care crisis it is breaking
families up and down this country and
collectively we've got to find a way to
deal with it if that means that those
who make their money out of
something other than income out of
assets pay a bit more if it means that
people pay a bit more on their income if
it means that we find some kind of
compromise that is sustainable so that
people who can pay a bit more do in
various different ways i think that's
the right approach to take i think we
need to be pragmatic but pensioners on
low incomes who happen to have paid off
their mortgages can't afford can't
generally speaking pay a bit more
well that is the reason why we've got to
learn from the failure to solve this
over the last 20 years because it is
complicated and there will be impacts on
people that
aren't as straightforward as saying one
group of people have to pay for all of
this or another group of people have to
pay for all of this the dill knot report
was an attempt to try to be creative and
a bit more flexible about how we manage
this but we've had this for so long now
in 2009 andy burnham put forward
proposals that collapsed because he
couldn't take the tories with him in
2017 theresa may sprung proposals on on
in her election manifesto that collapsed
because she couldn't take us or other
parties with her and now boris johnson
appears to have sprung a bunch of
proposals on his own party and can't
even take his own party with him we've
got to learn the lessons we've got to
work together to find a fair sustainable
solution to this that commands
thank you and if the prime minister
wants to talk about that our door is
open